alright um welcome thank you all for
coming I'd like to first of all thank
Roger hertog for his generosity for
making all this possible and this you
know is not just this lecture series
it's a research program it's a lot of
things I encourage you to look at our
website and see everything we're up to I
want to also thank the Arnold Saltzman
Institute for co-sponsoring this lecture
series and and also for the School of
International and public affairs for
providing this this beautiful venue so
thank you and thank you all for coming
and thank you too ambassador Bonnie
Jenkins to use the State Department's
coordinator for Threat Reduction and
it's a big job as we've been learning
over the course of this summer as many
of you already know but if there's
anybody who can do it i think it's
bonnie she has one of these resumes that
makes you feel insecure about yourself
and of course it's not just a resume but
let me just rattle off a couple of
things because it's really amazing she
has law degrees from from Georgetown and
see in the Albany she has her PhD in
international relations from UVA RBA and
Amherst and that's the least of it she
also recently retired as a lieutenant
commander from the US Naval Reserve she
also in the course of doing this and
many other things she periodically has
been deployed most recently she spent
Yura being deployed to CENTCOM for nine
years she was a legal adviser at the
arms control and disarmament agency
where she advised diplomats and
negotiating teams on a whole range of
international treaty negotiations in
addition to that she was on the staff of
the 911 Commission the air she was in
the lead in assessing how it is the
Department of Defense dealt with
al-qaeda and military plans in dealing
with al-qaeda she played a key role in
that report and after that for four
years she was the head of US foreign and
security policy programs at the Ford
Foundation so she did all this before
she took up this position as ambassador
Ford
reduction coordination State Department
and for all these reasons I think she's
really a wonderful addition to this to
this program so thank you so much
ambassador Jenkins for coming and thank
you all for being here it's over to you
Bonnie thank you very much thanks for
inviting me and I can tell I'm in 2010
with technology because i have i have
the powerpoint slides over there i have
this computer over here of notes over
here so i hope i can put it all together
for you into a coherent presentation can
everyone hear me okay i started my
position in June last year so I've been
there about a year so far and I think
one of the things that I find most
interesting is just how much the US
government is doing in the area of
cooperative adduction programs I'm going
to be going through a number of the
programs that we're doing right now in
the US government and some of our
international efforts and you'll get a
flavor of all the different things we're
doing to try to ensure that what was the
best instruction do not fall in the
hands of non-state actor and terrorists
and i welcome all your questions
afterwards on any of the programs that
we're doing i got to keep track of
what's going on up here as probably some
of you know after the Soviet Union fell
apart in 1990 there was a new threat
that was a that was facing the global
community we were facing a large WD and
weapons of mass destruction of WD
infrastructure of the former Soviet
Union there was no problem to us in a
very different way yet Russia and three
newly independent states Ukraine
Kazakhstan and Belarus that emerged and
inherited weapons of mass destruction
nuclear chemical and biological weapons
from the Soviet Union a lot of these
nuclear weapons were not secure there
was a concern about potential insider
theft and outside theft of course and
there were threats posed by the fact
that you had scientists with double D
knowledge who were unemployed and
could be sold to the highest bidder for
their need for their knowledge so there
was an immediate solution that was
required and we needed innovative
thinking and significant funding to
address what would eat new threats
fortunately senator nunn and senator
lugar recognized the importance of this
issue in importance of this new threat
and in November of 1991 both senator and
new senator nunn and Luger authored the
nunn-lugar Act which established the
guapa Threat Reduction program which
began in nineteen ninety to the original
purpose of non Luger is to secure a
dismantle weapons of mass destruction
and their associated infrastructure in
the former Soviet states it has provided
funding since 1992 and expertise for
states in the former Soviet Union to
decommission nuclear biological and
chemical weapons stockpiles under
disarmament treaties for example nuclear
weapons have been removed from their
delivery vehicles then decommission or
stockpiled at designated sites in Russia
it has destroyed and decommission these
missiles helping to ensure the security
and safety of nuclear weapons and
storage and it has also secured nuclear
material in civilian facilities
including radioactive sources and very
importantly it has engaged scientists
with w/d applicable expertise into other
non-threatening careers as examples of
the nonlocal successes and you can go to
the nunn-lugar site if you go to senator
Lugar's webpage you'll find all of this
he keeps a scorecard of all of his
successes I was the successes from the
CTR program and you will find that it
says that 7500 27 strategic nuclear
warheads have been deactivated 774
intercontinental ballistic missiles have
been destroyed 498 intercontinental
ballistic missiles have been eliminated
no silos have been eliminated on the 56
ICBM mobile launchers have been
destroyed 651 submarine-launched
ballistic missiles have been eliminated
476 submarine-launched ballistic missile
launchers have been eliminated
194 tests and tunnels nuclear test
tunnels have been eliminated 471 nuclear
weapons transport train train shipments
have been secured and and there's more
of course the focus of CTR has been on
states in the past because it was Russia
Ukraine Kazakhstan and Belarus that
inherited the nuclear weapons therefore
all the programs were focused on the
state level the threat that existed was
understood there had to be strong
efforts to destroy the weapons that were
out there and necessary funding was
provided the probe is particularly those
are destroying missiles for example
could be easily measured in terms of the
effect and how to count them it was a
visible showing of what was being done
the CTR programs were initially led by
three departments in the government the
Department of Defense which did a lot of
the destroying and decommissioning of
missiles and nuclear warheads and the
security and safety of nuclear weapons
and storage the Department of Energy did
a lot of work in securing nuclear
materials and civilian facilities
including radioactive sources and the
Department of State was engaged in
engaging scientists with w/d applicable
expertise
I think in my head okay however today
there's a recognition that the threat
has evolved you still have the threat in
a former Soviet Union that continues
however the threat today is no longer
predominantly against States therefore
we need to emphasize programs that focus
on non-state actors and terrorists the W
threat today is global it's no longer
Russia for and the former Soviet Union
and there are global actors the threat
is more diffuse and no longer just
within specific areas the new threat of
nuclear terrorism exists now but there's
also a new threat of bioterrorism and
new challenges raised by this newest new
type of threat the threat is different
in terms of the objects of concern it's
no longer just large facilities large
submarines but you're talking about
countries around the world vaio sites
bio pathogens and borders you have to
secure the borders as a result today CT
our efforts in combating emerging WD
threats have had the change there are a
number of recurring themes that underlie
a lot of the CTX CTR activities of today
as I said there's a global focus new
partnerships more countries are engaged
it's no longer just United States in the
United United Kingdom but a lot more
countries are engaged in the efforts
partnerships we use the word partner a
lot in our work with other countries the
activities are threat driven around the
world the activities go where the
threats exist there are a number of
different platforms have been created to
address these threats whether you're
talking about the Global Initiative to
combat nuclear terrorism the
proliferation Security Initiative
Security Council resolutions all of
these I'll go through there's increasing
international efforts and increasing
need to work together to address these
threats you see a lot more efforts on
regional activities focusing on
developing centers of excellence in
different parts of the world there's a
need to work with more actors NGOs
industry think tanks and in
national organizations like the wh 0
endowed this year in 20 2010 there's
been new legislation that was passed by
none Luke by senator lugar to address
these new threats for the Department of
Defense because right now up to this
point Department of Defense has only
been able to address threats in Russia
and the former Soviet Union whereas the
department of energy in Department of
State has been working outside those
areas for a while Synanon Luger has
stated that the program is the CTR
program is well positioned to enter a
new phase of global security engagement
none Luger is now more flexible to meet
unexpected threats in locations around
the world it has authority to spend ten
percent of its budget on what they call
notwithstanding authority now with the
ending story allows allows efforts to be
spent in any country regardless of
whether that country is on the terrorist
list or not a terrorist list is now
working beyond Russian a former Soviet
Union and it's now going to focus a lot
more work on bio security there are also
a number of new challenges one there are
many new platforms there are many new
mechanisms in which we're trying to
address these many new threats there are
many more activities as I mentioned
already bio security nuclear
radiological security border security
use Security Council resolutions the
Nuclear Security Summit it's a different
and unfamiliar landscape for a lot of
countries where do we go first will be
fun first do we do Barra security in
africa do we do nuclear security in asia
how much is it going to cost a lot of
these issues have to be addressed
funding concerns it's a tight world out
there in terms of funding how do we do
all these efforts with a tighter budget
there is a challenge of integrating more
international organizations into the
threat issue coordination big issue how
do we assess the impact of some of these
new threats and some of these new
activities
there's threat fatigue some kind of some
constituencies around the world
challenge whether some of these threats
exist and the sustainability how do we
make sure that these activities and what
we do are sustained
so what are some of the current
activities in which the u.s. is engaged
globally to combat Dermody terrorism and
how are the themes I noted reflected in
current activities the first we're going
to look at is a global initiative to
combat nuclear terrorism this is a this
is a forum that contained that now has
80 partners and when I say partners are
referring to countries the goal of the
public gic and t is a strengthen global
capacity to prevent detect and respond
to nuclear terrorism by conducting
multilateral activities it seeks to
improve the implementation and
coordination of existing national and
multilateral programs aimed at
curtailing nuclear trafficking and
avoiding duplication and demonstrating
resolve by building the capacity of
willing partners so they can combat
nuclear terrorism on a determined and
systematic basis the initiative seeks to
eliminate domestic operational or
technical challenges that impede the
fight against nuclear terrorism the GI
CNT is co-chaired by both the US and
Russia and was started in 2006 in last
month and they had a meeting of the GI
CNT they have an annual meeting every
year in addition to a number of other
meetings where they agreed upon a number
of new initiatives one of the things
they want to focus a lot on is something
called nuclear forensics which allows
you to be able to determine where if
there's a nuclear incident where the
incident may have started from where the
nuclear material may have originated
they do a number of activities including
exercises to improve collective
abilities to share information and
assess a complex radiological nuclear
threat they have some poems to detect
the section on special nuclear material
to discuss several detection techniques
and materials as well as highlight the
importance of government academia and
industry working closely together to
maximize potential for enhanced nuclear
detection capabilities and they host a
number of workshops next is the
proliferation Security Initiative this
is also a global effort that aims to
stop trafficking of WMD there
systems and related materials to and
from state and non-state actors of
proliferation concern exceeds the
cooperation of any state whose vessels
Flags port territorial waters airspace
or land might be used by proliferation
purposes for proliferation purposes by
States or non-state actors it was
launched in 2003 and now is 97 partners
it uses an innovative and proactive
approach that relies on voluntary
actions taken by States consistent with
their national legal authorities and
relevant international law and
frameworks nations meet regularly in the
context of exercises expert meetings and
plenary sessions in various world
capitals it tests and develops
cooperative procedures that would
minimize or detect the transportation
and smuggling of weapons of mass
destruction they are working now to
increase activities around the globe
including in Africa in South Africa and
Asia
nuclear smuggling there's a number of
programs that are at the Department of
State one is the nuclear smuggling
outreach initiative this builds
partnerships with key countries around
the world to combat the global threat of
nuclear smuggling in order to address
the problem in a comprehensive way it
assists nations with nuclear source
materials or who pose a high risk for
nuclear smuggling to improve their
capabilities in preventing detecting and
responding to incidents it works with
bilateral partners most affected by the
threat to develop joint action plans
specifying priority steps to improve
capabilities it sends an interagency
assessment team to part your country to
conduct a vigorous assessment of the
nation's existing capabilities and
regulations pertaining to nuclear
smuggling the assessment team
investigates country specific risk and
engages with officials from the address
nation together they determine precisely
Z requirements outlined in their joint
assessment a joint action plan is then
created outlining specific gaps and
tailored projects which will address the
shortcomings in the States and exploding
capacity as the at-risk countries begins
to its own efforts to address the items
on the list the nuclear smuggling out
reading initiative engages and matches
external donors both within the US and
outside the government to run projects
that will help the at-risk countries
moving on to nuclear to the preventing
nuclear smuggling this effort is to
promote international nuclear forensic
operation through national nuclear
forensics library's nuclear forensics is
a technical means by which nuclear
materials whether intercepted intact or
retrieved from post-explosion d'bries
are characterized as the composition
physical condition age in history and
interpreted and interpretive such as
industrial history and implications for
nuclear device design it can provide
evidence for determining the history of
the sample material and runs into
unfortunately the controversial issue of
attribution it works for countries to
improve anti some nuclear smuggling and
nuclear forensics capabilities by
providing funding for individuals to
participate in a number of international
workshops it addresses the kid
gaps in the capabilities of partner
nations to combat smuggling in nuclear
and radiological materials finally the
nuclear trafficking response group the
coordinates US government response to
incidents of illicit trafficking in
nuclear radio radio radioactive
materials it works with foreign
governments to secure smuggled nuclear
material including facilities where
divergence occurred to prosecute those
involved and develop information on
smuggled related threads it works
closely with law enforcement as well as
scientists overseas to ensure a process
for tracking smuggled materials next
slide moving on to another area that has
increased important as export controls
and related border security issues the
experts programs bolsters partner
countries capabilities to detect and
interdict illicit transfers of strategic
items radioactive materials and other
Douglas components as well as advanced
conventional weapons it provides
extensive training on strategic trade
control legislation licensing
enforcement in government industry
outreach and interagency coordination as
well as donates inspection and detecting
equipment to frontline enforcement
agencies it takes a regional and
multilateral approach to help harmonize
the recipient countries Export Control
regimes with international standards
while fostering greater information
sharing next page
Chemical security engagement the
chemical security engagement program
also at the State Department seeks to
reduce the threat of chemical terrorism
by preventing terrorist access to
chemical weapons and their precursors
toxic industrial chemicals and do use
infrastructure it seeks to raise
awareness about the multi-use nature of
chemicals promote laboratory best
practices and prevent sabotage or an
accidental release at a chemical
industrial facility its global
engagement efforts support the US
chemical defense policy as well as
international non-proliferation regimes
it works closely with host governments
and international partner nations to
identify needs and implement assistance
to ensure safe secure and sustainable
chemical laboratory best practices it's
working now in South and Southeast Asia
and will continue work towards
establishing centers of excellence
significantly expand efforts in the
Middle East and North Africa and
continue to grow new regional efforts in
West and sub-saharan Africa moving on
the bio the biological engagement
security violet the bio security
engagement program seeks to reduce the
threat of bioterrorism by preventing
terrorist access to potentially
dangerous state biological material and
do use infrastructure and expertise it
helps address global bio security risks
from bioterrorism and infectious disease
outbreaks through providing technical
assistance training and workshops on
strengthening biosafety and biosecurity
capabilities and developing safe secure
and sustainable lab capacity building
and national standards for comprehensive
biological security it deals in elements
of Baia as I said biosecurity and
biosafety but also as I said infectious
disease which is increasingly important
area today this is also global work it
works in Southeast Asia South Asia
Middle East and North Africa the Horn of
Africa and Latin America next please
another effort by the Department of
State is called a partnership for
nuclear security this effort establishes
sustainable linkages between nuclear
experts and priority countries and
counterparts at us and international
institutions it engages nuclear
scientists engineers and technicians and
collaborative research projects raises
awareness of government and nuclear
technical community about the threat of
proliferation and encourages effective
not leverage practices of policies it
improves nuclear safety and security
best practices by providing
opportunities for training to nuclear
professionals to workshop conferences
fellowships and exchange programs and
related activities where its work is in
sub-saharan Africa South Africa it's
launching efforts in the Middle East and
North Africa now that's one actually one
before that the nuclear facilities
mathematics posle project is training
and equipment to help Iraq make
preparations to dismantle and dispose of
their former nuclear facilities the
program has been initiated by the
Department of State to assist the
government of the government of Iraq and
eliminating the threats from poorly
controlled radioactive materials while
building human capacity so that the
Iraqi government can manage other
environmental cleanups in their country
department of state is funding the
international atomic energy agency to
provide technical assistance on these
projects it's addressing the
approximately a thousand radioactive
seal sources that are a problem in Iraq
the overall goal of the program is a
safety dispose of the contaminated
materials that were part of the former
nuclear program in Iraq and develop the
regulatory environments are necessary to
protect the citizens workers and future
generations from the hazardous effects
of the radiation
there are a couple more programs that we
deal with the partner state of working
on one is called the Iraq scientist
engagement program which gays engages
former deputy personnel and civilian
activities with an emphasis on Iraq
reconstruction efforts it was
established in 2003 and it seeks to
minimize the terrorism and proliferation
risk posed by Iraqi scientists
technicians and engineers with weapons
of weapons applicable expertise it
engages these individuals by sponsoring
technical trainings workshops seminars
conferences and grant competitions to
promote peaceful civilian application of
their skills it also promotes safety and
security best practices and Iraqi
facilities and laboratories that
produced use or store potentially
dangerous or do use biological chemical
and Radiological materials finally
there's the Libya scientists engagement
program which provides assistance in
reoriented living former WD scientist
towards event careers that can enhance
Libya's economic development the program
seeks to reduce the proliferation risk
of Libyan weapons of mass destruction
expertise by supporting the transition
of Libyan scientists technicians and
engineers previously engaged in WD in
its WD program to civilian careers in a
number of areas this very briefly talk
about Security Council resolution 1540
this was passed in 2004 and it obligates
each UN member to adopt domestic
controls to prevent the spread of
weapons of mass destruction it prohibits
support to non-state actors seeking such
items States want to stop effective
effective laws and prohibiting the
proliferation of such items to non-state
actors it was adopted under Chapter 7 of
the UN Charter and it calls on all
states to report their implementation of
a status to the Security Council
Committee since 2006 the number of
states with laws prohibiting non-state
actors from durban d activity has grown
from 14 to 63 and it is so growing it's
helping to forge new relationships
across bureaucracies enhancing
regulatory frameworks and addressing the
nexus between non-state actors and
weapons of mass destruction Security
Council resolution 1540 has high
hi attention very high level attention
and US government and the US government
is working to provide funding to assist
other countries requiring financial need
have financially to fulfill their
commitments it is positive that there
are numerous intergovernmental and
non-governmental related meetings and
gatherings to promote and international
support of dialogue on the issue next
please coming close early in here just a
few more the global initiative I mean
the global partnership against the
spread of weapons of mass destruction is
a trini brilliant two-year commitment by
the g8 that was launched in 2002 with
the aim of preventing terrorists and
States from acquiring or developing WMD
it now has 23 parties including the
European Union and it's been focused on
two areas destroying Russian nuclear
submarines and rushing chemical weapons
the u.s. counts all of its CTR efforts
in Russia and former Soviet Union
tortoise commitment of the 20 billion
has been committed to the US funds 10
billion of it is set to expire in 2012
and there are a number of goals we would
like to you know we would like to have
of course you want to extend the
partnership for another 10 years for
another 20 billion dollars but to also
make it so that it's much more
reflective of the threats of today we
want to bring in new partners we want to
bring have new activities that are
global and focused no longer focusing on
Russia and the former Soviet Union we'd
like to have new activities such as bio
security border security urine Security
Council resolution 1540 implementation
and of course radiological nuclear
security of facilities there was a
meeting in June the g8 summit and we see
experts advise said that they would like
to have any vibration of the results of
the GP that they would like to focus on
nuclear and Radiological security bio
security and sciences engagement and
1540 so we were able to get the things
that we thought were important
reiterated the need to prepare for the
potential participation of new countries
and acknowledged that the threat posed
by devin deen is ongoing and the work to
prevent the spread of it will continue
for years that's
next we just go back for a second just
to show who the partners for the ga
Google partners partnership is right now
hey Nick
forward
I just wanted to just say very briefly
about the Department of Defense I also I
already noted that they had new
legislation to do work outside Russia
and the former Soviet Union but one of
the big things are going to be seeing is
that they're going to be doing a lot
more work on buyer engagement and bio
security work which they have not done a
lot of traditionally and this is because
it's been a recognition in the US
government of the new threats posed by
bios and love and life sciences issues
so they're going to be doing a lot more
on this issue in the future just very
briefly about the Department of Energy I
won't go through this in detail just
want to mention that there are a number
of programs one is called the global
threat reduction initiative which is a
initiative to try to it's really the
focus of trying to secure all volvo
nuclear material by securing a material
at the source by converting on reactors
that use highly enriched uranium to low
enriched uranium and you need highly
rich arena to develop nuclear weapons to
actually remove the material which is
probably the best way to secure facility
ism is to get rid of it don't even have
to worry about threats and and
terrorists getting their hands on it and
they're active in over 90 countries i
believe working on this project working
on these projects the MP cna program the
material protection program essentially
is a program that really is the source
of securing the material at facilities
this is something deal we has been doing
for a number of years and they've done a
lot of work of course in russian former
soviet union so far they'll also be
doing a lot more work outside russian
former Soviet Union next one the border
security program that do we has it
actually puts radiation monitors at a
number of land borders at sea ports all
points of entry it's a global program
that they've been working on then you
have the international nuclear
safeguards and engagement program which
enhances safeguards by improving the
correctness and completeness of member
states declarations of nuclear material
and facilities thereby reducing the
likelihood of theft there's a prediction
at about 60 countries are considering
nuclear power to meet growing energy
demands which increase to increase the
burden of an already-strained safeguards
so these newcomer countries will require
training and expertise to ensure that
nuclear technology are used in
accordance with international
non-proliferation obligations to
facilitate the safe and secure global
expansion of nuclear energy this program
works with States to strengthen
safeguards and existing nuclear
facilities around the globe this is a
this is a program that was really
working directly with the new increase
in countries that want to develop
nuclear power to make sure that it's
done safe and it that's and securely
next please I've got to finish by
talking about the the the nuclear summit
one of my jobs at the department of
state is on the State Department rep to
the NSC White House working on a nuclear
security summit as I think probably most
of you know there was a summit in April
of this past April 47 countries were
invited three international
organizations the IAEA the UN was there
the European Union was there and one of
the there were a number of positive
outcomes from the summit there was a
communique that was agreed to and was
signed by all the participants that
basically that a consensus that the
danger of nuclear terrorism is one of
the greatest threats to our collective
security they agree that terrorist
networks have tried to acquire the
material for nuclear weapons and if they
succeed they will use it and where they
did do so it would be a category for the
world causing extraordinary loss of life
and striking a major blow to global
peace and stability so all these
countries that were were part of the
summit agreed to this the outcomes as I
said there was a communique there's a
work plan that came from that which
actually details for the net the
national international actions that
countries must take it had there were a
number of national statements that were
made and there are a number of bilateral
meetings that that were held by Obama
and his colleagues and his counterparts
around the world
okay next
if anyone has questions about the summer
weekend uh we can talk about that later
okay finally the four-year effort to
secure of all nuclear material this was
what was really launched by the Nuclear
Security Summit on the summit of course
was a one-day event will be having
another summit in 2012 in South Korea
but really what's following that is a
foyer effort to secure evolved a nuclear
material which is really being led by
Department of Energy and I talked about
the global threat reduction initiative
their effort to secure material to
remove nuclear material from facilities
to convert reactors so they can cannot
make the type of nuclear material that
can that can be used for nuclear weapons
this is an effort that President Obama
announced when used in Prague in 2009
and what the what the nucleus of
chemically summit really did was bring
high-level attention and focus on this
effort and to get buy-in from the number
of countries to actually dedicate
themselves to secure in volatile liquid
material in the next four years and
that's it so those I think are all I
can't say they're all the programs
there's programs in Department of
Commerce there's programs and DHS this
programs and the NR the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission but this gives you
a flavor of the type of CTR activities
that are on ongoing now and it gives you
a flavor how it's changed from when he
started and in 1992 just focused on
Russian former Soviet Union focused on
large projects so I was evolved to
global effort around the world with non
focusing on non-state actors with a
number of new type of activities that we
have today so for questions
thank you very much ambassador decades
so those who'd like to ask questions I
asked you to come to the to the center
the room will find a mic is yes sir i am
james hamilton from King's College my
question is how do you see the
relationship between the Cooperative
Threat Reduction programs and the other
multilateral initiatives like 1540 and
do you see in this complementary or do
you see the multilateral initiative is
ineffective and therefore needs
Cooperative Threat Reduction and I
believe that g8 voted not to renew their
global partnership when they last met
your thoughts on that would be
appreciated thank you all of these
efforts are really should work together
and that's one of the goals we have and
if you if you have a chance to look at
the the work plan for the Nuclear
Security Summit you'll see that in it
there's a number of activities that
states will be taking to ensure that
nuclear material are secure and in it
you'll see things like 1540 you see the
Jago a partnership you see the global
initiative on you see nuclear forensics
you'll see how all of these efforts are
really supposed to be working together
to achieve the goal of nuclear security
and that's an example of how we see all
these efforts working together I will
say it's a lot and then when we go when
I go overseas and talk with officials
they do say with us a lot going on you
know there's so many there's so many
things happening but one of the things
we wanted to do with the with the summit
and the work plan was to show that there
is a way in which these all these things
have to work together on included with
1540 because 1540 works is has a lot of
language that deals with export controls
for example so the expo control folks
work closely with the 1540 folks there's
things and there that deal with with
nuclear smuggling with the proliferation
Security Initiative talking about that
so there's we have people that actually
work together on these issues because
they hate their they are connected so we
do see them as working together very
closely the g8 summit we did not get the
renewal this year the extension
here as you probably know we have two
years to get it we wanted to start early
because we wanted to give countries an
opportunity to get their budgets
together if they need to give budgets to
plan for it plan ahead for 2012 we
Canada was chair this year of the g8
they were a chair when the G equal
partnership started it was a symbolic
for them to be chair again we had
extension but we have we have two more
years so France chairs the g8 next year
I'm going to be traveling over to France
and September to start talking with them
about the game plan next year for trying
to ensure extension of the global
partnership in 2012 the u.s. chairs the
g8 hopefully we'll have it by then but
we have two years in which to get it and
I think the decisions that were made at
the last g8 I think we're big step
forward because they recognize the four
areas new areas we want to focus on
nuclear a logical security bio
engagement 1540 and bio security and
they recognize that the threats going to
exist for a number of years they said
years and that they we need to work
together as partners to address those
threats so it's a very big step in the
right direction hi I just wanted to know
for all these programs which countries
are organizations are the main financial
contributors or where do you guys get
the word of these organizations get the
funding from there are those are the
major contributors and those who are
very instrumental obviously the US the
UK Canada the ROK is doing a lot
Australia New Zealand um let's see no
way Japan France so you have a number
who are the traditional players but
you're starting to see a lot of other
countries want to play a much larger
role in these issues so which is a good
thing
hi thank you for your presentation I
think being presented with all of these
programs kind of reassuring seeing how
many people are working on reducing the
threat of nuclear terrorism and these
sorts of things since funding seems to
be a problem with having so many
organizations what sorts of things do
you do to tell the average American
about these programs to sort of
encourage them to vote for
representative supporting your
organizations and those sorts of things
is there sort of a disconnect because a
lot of these things seem completely new
to me and I think a lot of people don't
realize how much is being done so right
you're right most people don't know
what's being done I mean when one of my
purposes here is and when I talk to
audiences is to let them know there's a
lot going on that it's under the radar
screen that you're not aware of that the
government is engaged in both you know
domestically of course but
internationally to try to deal with
these issues and it's unique it's an
interesting situation because we have we
have been blessed by having a senator
who cares a lot about this and having
senator nunn there has been very helpful
because we've always gotten an increase
in funding every year since it started
now the question will the question would
be what happens with senator Lugar's not
there anymore you don't have the
champion and we cannot we can hope that
is picked up now when President Obama
was a senator he was also very much
engaged on these issues he talked a lot
to senator lugar about CTR and all this
effort so he knew a lot about this
before he became president but he's not
innocent anymore either so we've been
blessed and since that it's been an
issue that it's hard to argue against in
the Congress I mean you know it's hard
to argue against wanting to secure
weapons wanted to train scientists i
mean the arguments sometime is how do
you how to prove the success when it
comes to things like scientists
engagement but when you're talking about
big projects it's not hard to show why
they're successful why i should do it so
we've been very lucky we're very lucky
and we've been able to get the funding
that we need we haven't had it we
haven't had the need to go out and
convince the constituency around the
u.s. about it
was quite frank a lot of constituent
don't want to hear my boot over here
about these things but the bit they're
more than happy to let Washington handle
some of these of less sexy areas but but
we've been lucky and so the question
will be one what happens when Luger is
not there anymore to since a lot of
these programs now are less are less the
big-ticket destruction items will still
be doing that but you have a lot more
diffuse work smaller projects securing
pathogens here and work with scientists
there how will we sell that to the hill
as important and measurable and that
will be a challenge as well thank you
Logan ambassador thank you for coming
I'm Christopher brownfield a participant
in the hotel global strategy initiative
my question is how does the globe the
threat initiative Threat Reduction work
with countries like India and Pakistan
who are not part of the G aids they are
in the g20 but they're not really any
sort in any sort of framework that's
dealing with other non-proliferation
issues since they're not part of the
non-proliferation treaty and I'd like to
ask this question with particular
emphasis toward the recent us-india
nuclear agreements were we have
agreements for civilian nuclear fuel and
it seems strange to me that they aren't
part of the direct engagement for
Cooperative Threat Reduction also I'd
like to point out that the foreign
minister for Pakistan requested similar
civilian nuclear deal from Secretary
Clinton who responded very bluntly no we
are not going to cooperate with you on
civilian nuclear matters even though
Pakistan seems to be a very important
partner in the US for in Afghanistan so
I'm just like if if you could address
some of these issues about the seeming
lack of cooperation with India and
Pakistan on one hand and the need for
engagement with them on the other thank
you well there there are CTR type things
that go on with India and Pakistan we
have we're starting to get more engaged
with them on some of the
some of the bio issues at the Nuclear
Security Summit india and china
announced that they're going to set up
centres of excellence so we're working
very closely with them on that so there
are things that we work with them on
border security issues so and they
belong to some of these other groups and
we've been doc you do not part of the g8
but they're part of some of the other
groups out there so they are engaged
there's just so many of them sorry know
which ones but they are engaged and some
of the work that we are doing whether
it's in state or do we or do D or one of
the other agencies we are engaged in
those countries just may not be as
visible as some the other ones as far as
a Pakistan issue I can happily say
that's not in my portfolio but I do
understand which I do I know I
understand the question you're asking
and I you know my unders you know it's
not my issue but I know that we do have
relations with Pakistan on a number of
issues i don't i don't believe the
situation right now is ripe for that
kind of an agreement with pakistan so
that's why there has not been an
agreement to have one but we are working
with them in other ways in other in
other contexts and see what can happen
in future
hello good evening and thank you for the
presentation my name's Anne Lynn master
student from the center of peace and
Conflict Studies in Sydney and I'm not
at all specialized in that area so I
hope you'll forgive me for the
candidness of my questions one question
I had was in your presentation you said
that you you were trying to reoffend in
Iraq who are working on weapons of mass
destructions I thought there were no
weapons of mass destruction found so I i
was just seeking clarification and my
second question was i'd like to know a
bit more in more detail with the US are
doing in their own country I'm sorry I'm
French so maybe that's I'm more
interested in that what the United
States is doing in their own country inn
in this respect I recently read about an
incident or a study on the population of
fallujah in Iraq which showed very high
levels of cancer and birth defects which
were higher than those found after
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and which point
to use of weapons and nuclear weapons in
in by the US I suppose in in that
context so if you could if you could
give some some information later so I
would make sure I understand your second
question in the Iraq situation that
these are scientists who were working in
prior when Iraq was working on WMD so
they are scientists who have knowledge
but it's also scientists who there's two
definitions there was a scientist
redirection scientist engagement
scientist redirection are scientists who
at some point we're working on w date
and scientists engagement are scientists
who have not been working on it but have
the skills that they can use those
skills for WMD so it's it's you know
it's a it's both in and in Libya it's
more of a redirection because there were
a scientist who worked on their program
and the second question and what did you
ask what we're doing in the US
yes I find that the u.s. seems to be
very committed in this in this process
and you mentioned a lot of initiatives
around the world working in particular
risky countries i suppose especially
where border control is concerned but i
suppose in in thinking of nuclear Risk
Reduction you have two things you have
one reducing the number of nuclear
weapons and i would include the US who i
think has a lot of nuclear weapons and
also preventing them from being used and
what i what i read recently about this
study in fallujah is at the US it looks
like i don't think it's been completely
asserted yet but it looks like the US
has been using weapons of mass
destruction themselves nuclear weapons
in fallujah on the first one as far as
reducing nuclear weapons i mean that's a
it's been a very big part of President
Obama's agenda if you go back to the
product speech speech he talks about the
about reduction of nuclear weapons and
he says you know it may not ever happen
in his lifetime but there's no reason
why we can't start the process reducing
nuclear weapons so he's very committed
to that a lot of the initiatives that he
has he has started since he's been here
or strengthen since he's been here is
really to try to start the process or or
at least to start the process people can
think it's possible you know I think
there's a there's a feeling that it can
never happen but you have to at least
start thinking it's possible you can
start down so you said that for instance
some of the Russian nuclear submarines
who are dis mental do you have any such
examples in the US um no cheese quite
frankly I'm not sure what how we're
doing our nuclear submarines I'm pretty
sure we don't have nearly as many as we
used to have because they're not as
practical um so without knowing the
details of how many we have I'm pretty
sure we don't have that many we probably
destroy some of our own a lot of time
things are done kind of we try to have
some kind of evenness but I don't know
for sure is that far yes
no sorry do you have any information on
use of nuclear weapons by the middle
Jimmy no I are you referring to use of
like depleted uranium shells I think you
know depleted uranium is used in u.s.
ordnance and there are you know
questions is the health consequences is
that what you're talking about yes i was
i was asking about the use of nuclear
weapons in the in u.s. poverty policy
sorry i mean these are not nuclear
weapons in the sense that they they're
not you know triggering nuclear
reactions you know nuclear explosions
they're using you know depleted uranium
in ordnance because it's particularly
dense and it's effective against you
know armor etc so i just want to make
sure i understand it's not in the
category of weapons of mass destruction
is that what you're saying it doesn't
fall in that category the term it sorry
i'm not knowledgeable on that topic at
all obvious Lisa all right I mean no
it's not I mean it wouldn't be
considered what was a masterstroke yeah
oh God thank you not not that no no okay
thank you
I ambassador thanks for speaking with us
uh it's actually a related question but
it's on a policy level hmm Hans Blix who
spoke with this group at the beginning
of the summer recently mentioned in
print that he felt that the United
States was quote high on military in
2002 and 2003 with the release of its
national security strategy and the
resultant us-led invasion of Iraq on the
basis of WMD Graham Allison who also
spoke with us said that that invasion in
the lack of underlying justification was
the greatest cost was in fact a
stabilization of the region and other
nuclear powers essentially perhaps
accelerating their programs as a result
of regime instability so I would ask as
a result of the experience of the United
States unilateralism in Iraq how has the
administration and how does the CTR 20
contemplate American unilateralism or
potentially unilateralism by another
power as a contributor to the global
threat what restrictions if any have
been contemplated or put in place on the
United States is future behavior to
avoid additional unilateral adventures
where perhaps a structure like this
could be more effective well see the
make sure I understand your question but
the CTR program is always based on it's
not really a unilateral programmer can't
be implemented in years a lateral way
because everything that we do has to be
done with the consent of the other
country so we can't go into a country
and force them to accept our secure
their facility or we can't go into a
country enforce their scientists to
listen to us about bio security we can't
force a country to secure their
pathogens it's always voluntary and it
has to be voluntary to work what's it
becomes involuntary it's a different
type of thing so this doesn't really
have a lot of connection with
unilateralism per se if anything because
of the multilateral nature of it because
of the benefits that you gain by working
with other countries
um the experiences that you share do
these interactions if anything it works
against unilateralism and it promotes
more multilateral cultural exchange and
and scientists who you know scientists
always have their own language you got a
letter from so it promotes that and I
think it works against any notions of
unilateralism because of the very nature
which is which is done which is
implemented so they think it could be
used it seemed more as a positive but
usually says a lot of times we are
coming in with the funding to help them
we're saying you know we you know you're
such a situation of changes pathogens is
it is a threat to everyone and we would
like to help you and if they say no we
can't force them to accept it but a lot
of times we'll come in there with with
funding to help I guess just to clarify
very specifically in shortly um with the
United States showing financial
leadership showing conceptual leadership
in this initiative how has the united
states represented itself as a
forward-looking power learning from
whatever mistakes we may have made based
on one's perception to avoid
participants themselves conducting
themselves the way we did in 2003 I
think it's the way in which we carry
ourselves I think I think I think a lot
of us in a very nature of the way in
which Obama has come in the office and
the reception that he's received I know
I feel it whenever I travel overseas and
I talk with other countries it's a
different perception about the United
States and I think not that they think
we're great I mean ever not me i'm not
going to say where you know everyone
thinks are wonderful but I could
definitely say that the perception
itself in the way in which were seen I
think that helps a lot in a lot of what
a lot of what you're saying and what
you're talking about so this it's not
always a particular program a
particularly thing you do it's how you
how you present yourself and how you
work with other countries and the
perception that they get from the way
you are we're not always trying to we
are not always being you being a partner
like I said you use the word partners a
lot these days because that's how
countries want to be seen they want to
be seen as partners and there are times
when they lean on United States to be a
leader
and they wanted to be in particular in
these areas they felt there's been an
absence of the United States in
leadership in a lot of these WD areas
and they welcome the United States
leadership back in these areas but it's
also how you but you know being a leader
means sometimes being a follower you can
be a leader it out being in front so a
lot a lot of it's on a perception how
you present yourself Thank You
ambassador for your presentation my name
is chell jus come from depaul university
as I'm Chinese I'm really curious about
one nation close to my country which is
some a country you know doing a lot of
issue with nuclear weapons that is North
Korea I listen to your presentation and
I find a lot of program but I didn't see
a lot of like a specific focus on that
recommendation but actually we hear a
lot of things about what is going on in
North Korea what is going on about that
country and we also heard a lot about
like the Six Nations conference between
like Russia United States China Japan
North Korea and South Korea but it's
called like people are getting tiring to
hear about what is going on because
North Korea is really unstable they do
one thing the grid on one thing and they
did suddenly to change their mind so do
you see any possibility or new
opportunities for the United States
especially this prospective I mean to
see is there anything what going on in
the near future about the North Korea
issue or united states were way down to
your some sudden change or we can we all
knows that the great leader of that
nation was trying to pass on the power
to the next generation so do you see any
change a possibility of changing
anything or new opportunities or unites
do united states have some new solution
other than the beijing conference result
thank you um thanks thanks a question
well to some degree or we are as I
mentioned early these particular
programs I mean there's a lot of there's
a lot of platforms in which the US are
trying to do it North Korea
unfortunately these particular programs
you need to have
a country that's working with you so
these programs cannot really be
implemented in North Korea until North
Korea is open to these kind of programs
what I will say is that we there was a
point when we did have Department of
Energy folks probably state folks in
North Korea to dismantle some of their
facilities and then they kicked us out
and so we haven't been back but we have
funding that still set aside for that so
as soon as that situation changes we can
send people right back we've also when
we one thing that we did the United
States was trying to determine we're as
we talk about extending the global
partnership for another 10 years we had
to think in terms of what would we do in
the next 10 years but we'll be spending
money on and we did account for future
work in North Korea so we have been
thinking in terms of it putting aside
funding waiting for an opportunity to go
back and do some of these kind of
efforts in North Korea but unfortunately
we are we're stuck until there is some
kind of a change to some other some of
the other mechanism of the US government
and diplomacy can open up a possibility
that we can come in and do what we can
do okay thank you all right thank you
for the great presentation my name is
Mohammed Hawaiian mesh from the her talk
initiative and I actually had a question
about the impact of the of kind of these
alternative nonproliferation regimes on
the NPT as the cornerstone of
international non-proliferation regime
in terms of these alternative measures
and mechanisms undermining obviously
that's that's going to be on to
unintended consequences of these
alternative regimes and creating a
situation where countries don't take the
NPT seriously anymore and i think the
the nuclear deal with india gives even
more credence to to such concerns that
now we have a gray area of countries
that neither belong to the NPT nor do
not belong there and we've created kind
of a you know halfway house for those
types of countries
and I was wondering if you're thinking
you think these uh by not incorporating
these alternative measures in to the MPT
were action actually undermining that
cornerstone regime I'm not sure how us
how we would incorporate I mean the
impetus the MPT is is as you're saying
it's it's a it's a it's been very
successful in many ways but it is
fraught with a lot of problems and it's
almost in a sense it's almost it's
almost its own entity because of the
issues with disarmament and
non-proliferation and I can say for
example when we were working on the
Nuclear Security Summit which was in
April and the NPT review conference
which was in May I believe it was there
was always a need to keep the two
separate because we didn't want to we
didn't want to have the unfortunate
firestorms in the NPT Indian nuclear
security summit because it was very
important if you were going to have the
countries that we had at the summit
including India Pakistan Egypt mexico
brazil israel who were all part of the
Nuclear Security Summit you had to keep
it very very focused on nuclear security
securing nuclear material something that
no country could really argue against
but that highlights the fact that the
NPT is a is a I dont 16 closer that's
too big oh that's too big an emphasis
but it is its own entity and it has it
has its issues and it has its problems
so I think that if anything some of
these cooperative programs in which for
example well maybe maybe it's maybe the
center of excellence and India may do
something i don't know but maybe if
these these programs are an opportunity
for countries to interact and anytime
you have that kind of interaction and
working together there could be positive
effects in in many areas maybe in the
NPT as well
but you're right i mean the npt is a
situation of its own entity in a sense
and so it's you have to deal with them
in certain ways in order to make things
work if I can follow up on them very
quickly because I have this feeling that
the that the power of the npt comes from
the fact that not being a member to the
NPT is associated with some sort of
normative stigma and I think by creating
these alternative mechanisms we kind of
undermine that normative you know power
of the NPT so you might be not a member
to the MBT but make up for that not
maker membership through you know being
part of these other alternative
non-proliferation regimes um I'm not so
sure that that's the way it's seen i
don't i'm not so sure that the embassy
parties would say that well because you
know pakistan or india is a part of one
of these regimes that that somehow it's
okay or if a country that's part of the
NPT that's a problem country is part of
another regime that that's somehow
reduces their there the fact that
they're probably MPT I'm not sure that
people see that that way I mean it could
be it could be the case but I don't
think that in the NPT review conference
that they had in May than anybody would
say to a problem country you're part of
these other regimes so it's okay we're
not going to give you as much as a hard
time I don't think that's the case i
think the NPT is its own entity and it's
so it's talking about getting rid of
nuclear weapons talking about the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons and
that's an issue that we've been dealing
with for you know since the 40s so I
don't think that these in any way takes
away from the obligations that countries
have any amputate I mean I could be
wrong but I don't think so
ambassador thanks for your service in
the Navy in the state department at my
name is Alex leach just finished a grad
program at LSC I have two questions for
you first out of all these threats which
ones or keeps you up at night either
based on likelihood or total impacted my
cause and the second one is what sort of
bureaucratic challenge do you think is
the biggest that you deal with
day-to-day inside the US government and
keeping these disasters from occurring
ah what keeps me up at night I chef see
pretty well I think if these would
bother me that much I probably be doing
it but I guess I guess um maybe bio
security more so because one of the
biggest questions everyone always asks
is how come there hasn't been a
biological attack and you anywhere I
mean of a real significance in recent
years you know with nuclear weapons you
have to have the material and have to
have the facilities you have to have a
number of things to actually make a
weapon you can make a dirty bomb a lot
easier of course because radiological
materials are more accessible but you
know biological is this it's a dual use
entity where you know scientists have
the ability they have the knowledge to
do very good or very bad with the same
skills and you know it's it's it's not
as easy of course to do it as one would
think because there's I'm not a
biologist and my colleague is over there
but I know you know there's certain
things about temperature you know that
have an effect on how you how about
biology pathogens can can really affect
a large number of people but it does
make me wonder why it hasn't happened
and you don't want to ask the question
we don't ask other people to question
people do ask the question but it makes
me wonder why that hasn't happened and
that scares me because it can it's a
type of thing that can spread before
people know what's wrong what what
caused it if you see any of these movies
that they've made on on biological
terrorism there was one with Dustin
Hoffman I think what's called outbreak
that was made a number of years ago if
you see that movie
you get a real sense of how dangerous it
could be and it could be a naturally
current disease and that's the other
thing it doesn't have to be an
intentional an intentional threat to
somebody an intentional biological
effort it could be a naturally occurring
disease that happens and it can have the
same effect and so it's a that's that's
what I think is probably more scary to
me the bureaucratic challenges time very
very basic things there's a this time
there's personnel not having enough
people to do these issues to work on
these issues understanding the the
number of organizations that are engaged
in these issues trying to get a sense of
the lay of the land has been a challenge
there has been very good interagency
coordination overall between among the
different agencies that's been developed
through the year since 1992 and that's
good because it wasn't always that way I
think it started there were a lot of
bureaucratic fights I think between DoD
and do a State Department Holly ever
gets money so you know we're not really
renault reviewing the fight we though we
do lead the it in all the international
work but that's been that's a lot better
now and it but it can always be improved
and one of my job's is to find out ways
in which to improve it but it's basic
stuff it's uh it's not only that it's
not only the huge huge actors involved
in CTR but it's a there's never enough
people there's never enough funds to do
the work and just not enough time you
know it's a lot that we're doing a lot
could I ask you follow up on those two
questions the first in regards to
biosecurity as you point out it can be
difficult you know to separate out the
threat of naturally occurring pathogens
from a bio weapon that would be you know
built to kill people but do you have any
concern about the way that issues of
Public Health might be defined as
national security issues this a long
debate among people
work on environmental policy and
environmental scarcities about how it is
when you characterize some of the
environmental change or environmental
scarcity as a national security threat
that has all kinds of implications in
terms of how you deal with that
challenge mm-hmm and so that would be a
question I'd be curious to hear your
responsive the the other one I'll wait
for it but go ahead on no I think you're
right i think when you put a security
lens on on something it does change it
and well it brings in different actors
and it brings in different specialists
and sometimes individuals who have never
work together before it brings in and
and then you know there's all types of
sensitivities that arise turf battles
that arise funding issues that arise and
certain and there is a certain you know
when you say security it's it's did you
think threat and you know scientists who
may be doing something because they
wanted they feel like they're doing it
for you know the betterment of health in
the in the united states we just put the
threat lens on it changes it in a
certain in a certain way and it's seen
as more of a negative in a sense so i
think there's a reluctance to do that to
some degree i know in the bio area we've
been just you know we just State
Department has been funding CDC and
Department of Agriculture to do work in
overseas because they don't really have
a budget to do bio security type work
and if we think that might change and
they may actually start getting a budget
to focus on security bio security issues
so it's still in its infancy in terms of
that and I'm sure it is true in so many
other areas as well environmental or
whatever that you when you put the
security lens it just change the
perception of it though at one point
when security was the big thing there
was an attraction to it because you got
more money from the government because
everything was security security but it
does change it that anticipates my
second question there was a series in
the Washington Post recently about the
business of Homeland Security how it's
become a big business many thousands
people making a living
from it and you know many of them making
a better living in the private sector as
usual than they used to make in
government is is that a concern for you
the privatization of important national
security programs in even policymaking
and also the the competition for talent
you know when they're a private sector
when there's private sector demand for
the talents that the government needs as
well if only to deal with all the
Beltway bandits a nua mm-hmm I would say
not so much for me because in my world
I'm not really dealing with a lot of
private sector folks DHS probably has a
lot more of a concern with that but most
of my world is international most of the
private if you call them private would
be individuals come from Department of
Energy National Laboratories like sandy
OR Los Alamos so they're not really
really independent because I they're
also funded by the government but
they're not DC there you know Sandhya in
California or Santa Fe but in my world I
don't really deal with that in terms of
a competition with them but there may be
there may be situations where for some
reason the government is not able
because the one thing that somebody's
some of the private sectors can do is
they can take a longer look at some
issues because in the government
everything it you know it's so busy that
sitting back and looking at things
strategically you don't have a lot of
time to do that and sometimes you you
have folks from outside do some of that
for you and look at things in a
strategic much more of a strategic level
and come back and give you some ideas
and some thoughts and that's what some
of these labs these department of energy
laboratories do for doee is they're able
to do that they're able to look at not
only do they do a lot of the technical
workers the scientist at terrible
scientific technical work but they are
able to sit back and give a strategic
view on policy or whatever and a lot of
times you just don't have the time to do
on everyday basis in the government
ambassador what do you think the
administration's assessment of and
thinking about
the threat of the expansion of nuclear
energy worldwide the White House itself
estimates that the number of nuclear
reactors globally will double by
mid-century and that this will carry
lots of proliferation risks but at the
same time President Obama's Blue Ribbon
Commission is considering as relooking
at the reprocessing issue domestically
and nuclear energy is going to be needed
by growing powers that are growing
economically and that want to lower
their carbon emissions in order to me
mitigation goals to prevent global
climate change if there is a way if
there was a way to deal with the energy
problems we have today in the world
without more nuclear without doing it
through nuclear energy that would be
great simply because nuclear energy by
building nuclear energy and nuclear
power using nuclear energy and polly
nuclear power gives you the skills and a
facility to build nuclear weapons I mean
you need facilities you mean materials
and stuff but still it gives you the
basic knowledge to do it but it's a
writer every country every country has a
right to do it so you can't tell
countries date they can't do that so the
really the issue is how to country how
do you ensure that countries do that in
a way that's not in a non-proliferation
way and one of the programs i was
talking about the do ii does is just
that it works with countries that want
to develop nuclear power and help them
understand how to do it safe and secure
and aware of non-proliferation concerns
and and threats that having all this
nuclear power does create so it's it's a
countries have the right to do it you
can't say they can't do it it's just how
do you do it in a managed way it's a
real issue mm-hmm thank you for your
talk my name is John Koch I follow
Korean Affairs closely and there's a
connection between the preview
comment and your presentation involving
a proliferation Security Initiative
which I'd like you to comment on and and
here's the gist of what what is involved
it's my understanding that the
proliferation Security Initiative
presage some of the harsher sanctions
imposed recently against North Korea
which mandates States to inspect cargoes
for military shipments and WMDs and so
forth now the participants in that
initiative did not include South Korea
initially because the administrative
because the government in South Korea
didn't want to offend the north but the
new government of President Lee
myung-bak as distinguished the
government of Roman Young has signed on
and I think they signed on even before
the recent attack against the North
Korean ship so here's my question here
you have an example of a participant
which changes its position with a change
in regime with a change of
administration and it can work the other
way so you have players joining or
abstaining depending on their national
interests so how do you deal with that
well first of all yes the ROK is a has
is joining the perforation Security
Initiative so that's true it you know
that's something that you really can't
control and for the most part for the
most part overall that doesn't happen
for the most part when countries join
these regimes are pretty much stay in
them but because we talk about 90
countries or so but you know if you ever
change and they pull out all you can
really do is engage with them to try to
stay involved and if they pull out of
this they may pull out of a lot of other
things and so youryour diplomacy with
that country would really focus on
staying engaged in these on these
efforts and that's how your diplomacy
for that country would adjust to the
change in what they do
yeah you're right it does definitely
does I think this will be the last
question thank you very much for your a
very interesting lecture well yeah the
non-traditional security and become more
and more important now is especially the
energy a climate change thread thread
and not only via United States but also
the whole world so I can't hear what
you're saying you say there are energy
screech and a climate change and threat
not only the United States master all
the world's a lot as a crazy idea what
the united states adopt what policy at
occupy the united states in the air
energy and climate change field and
what's the multilateral cooperation to
the energy security stretching nowadays
thank you thinking about what the
multilateral cooperation to the air and
it's crazy of threatening threat I guess
are you asking her to speak to a US
policy on on climate change of energies
mount original trying to do this or NLC
latter away yeah yeah non-traditional
threats yeah and climate change um well
non-traditional threads are you talking
about just natural threats in general or
just trying and just climate change I
mean in in terms of I mean I'm not I'm
not going to speak to know the climate
change issue because I so like out of my
head of my portfolio um but
non-traditional threats you know it
depends on how how you're defining them
i mean if you're talking about the kind
that i work with then these are the ways
of what you're trying to deal with them
we just have a number of mechanisms that
exists that try to i mean we haven't we
almost have a mechanism for almost
everything that's out there we have a
mechanism to interdict we have a
mechanism to for nuclear forensics to a
few
you detect if you blow something up
we're trying to figure out where it came
from you have mechanisms secure the
materials at the source you have a
mechanism to secure about the borders
whether it whether there WWD in general
so in terms of the issues I work on this
there's pretty much a mechanism for
almost every path that materials for
example nuclear materials can go from a
facility into the hands of a terrorist
and then getting this getting the
materials out of the hands of terrorists
so we kind of have everything covered in
all the different areas just have to
belong to some of them but it's if
you're talking about in that respect we
have programs that deal with
non-traditional threats in terms of
anything that's divinity related climate
change I'm not that's not my area so I
can't really answer that one all right
oh you've already out of foam I can read
about it tell you all right thank you
again ambassador Jack thank thank you